Hello friends um I am Isabelle Zimmerman
uh and I'm here to talk about some docs
and you can talk about documentation in
a lot of different ways uh you could
talk about how to write really
accessible explanations to like
technical terms or you could talk about
how to write examples that people can
just like copy and paste from your
documentation and it looks great and it
works every time um but I am an open-
Source software engineer at posit which
means I kind of am always in the mindset
of thinking of things as tooling
problems and documentation is no
different uh the r ecosystem has a
really well-loved documentation tool
called package down and if you're an R
user and you've seen package down
documentation you probably don't even
realize all of the Fantastic benefits
you're getting from this uh as a user
you you log on or not log on you just
like pull up a package down site and you
have this this beautiful index page
which is actually also the github's read
me and then you have some tabs up at the
top and there's like one that says
reference and you click on that to see
the functions and then there's usually
something that says like read more or
articles and then you go there if you
need to have like certain workflows uh
and if you are a developer you also
really benefit from this uh I was told
that you can actually build a package
down site in less than 1 minute and you
don't have to trust me this came from
Jenny Bryan and I think it was
established yesterday that we can in
fact trust Jenny
Bryan but I am in the python space and
uh a little bit different than the very
well engineered uh our world it kind of
feels like the wild west out here when I
started building this package Vier I
really struggled to find a tool that
felt just right to create package
documentation and in fact you could say
I felt a little bit like Goldilocks And
if you're not familiar with the tale
Goldilocks is a children's story of a
young girl and she's lost in the woods
and she finds a house and nobody's home
and I guess she just like decides to
walk in uh and start messing with the
homeowner's stuff and it's super cool
they apparently left mid- breakfast and
she's going to eat all of their food and
she tries this first bowl of porridge
and it's freezing cold she tries the
next bowl of porridge and it's like
scorching scorching hot and the last one
is just
right she ends up messing up like all
the homeowner stuff and then she like
sleeps in their beds and then some
home-owning bears come back uh and she
realizes that it was the Bears that
inhabit the house the whole time uh but
they allegedly live happily ever after
and while Goldilocks might have been
like legally breaking and entering uh we
view this in the maybe more childlike
lens of this is someone who approaches a
face that they believe uh maybe misled
uh but they believe it's been built just
for them and she knows what she wants
like Goldie loocks knows she wants this
perfect porridge and nothing feels just
right and when I started making my first
dock site I felt this frustration of
knowing what I wanted in my
documentation I wanted something that
was super maintainable uh kind of
offload that mental load uh to the
documentation framework I wanted it
maintainable I wanted to be markdown
based that would be super useful uh I
love markdown and I wanted more than
anything this documentation system to
give users everything that they need to
be successful when they're using my
packages and because we're living in a
fairy tale land of docs Utopia it would
also be really cool like if this tool
didn't import a lot of weird things I
didn't have to Wrangle a bunch of other
dependencies uh and overall I just
wanted it to allow me to have more time
to focus on the content of the site
rather than like fiddling with all of
these weird settings but the tools at
hand were feeling not just
right the one thing I knew I needed in
this documentation system is long format
docs and that's kind of to tell people
the when and the why uh to use different
packages and the our world really has
this down to a science uh in fact they
have a whole name for it called
vignettes and vignettes are great for
telling a story uh it gives context to
some sort of like small workflows uh
that a package is useful for
doing and you can see it you know in
these package Downs sites you click on
the Articles you see the vignettes and I
tried to use a tool in Python that was
really excellent in Long format
documentation this tool is called make
docs and it was great to get started it
felt pretty ergonomic uh and what that
was really exactly what I wanted I could
write some
markdown but I realized actually um my
users cannot live on vignettes alone uh
while people were fantastically prepared
preped for like when to use docs and why
they should be uh running this fer code
there wasn't much intuition on like how
to use certain functions If I Only Had
vignettes and like examples so this
documentation tool was not just right in
order to get this API docs I'd have to
Wrangle a bunch of extensions and it
just didn't really feel like something
um that I wanted to do with this docs
tool so to fill this Gap I knew I needed
function references and this is showing
people how to run
code and when I write my Python scripts
uh I write it in a pretty structured way
you know you define your function you
have your function name we've seen a lot
of code over this conference and you
probably are almost like just uh
ingesting this naturally you know
there's these uh parameters underneath
you see these three triple like quotes
there's a line describing the function
there's parameters there's a line
underneath it uh and then there's some
like special indentation it's structured
in a very very particular
way and this is on purpose uh this is
because there are tools out there to
programmatically export this doc string
uh into beautiful beautiful websites
here you can see uh I used a uh package
called Sphinx and I could get my
function name the package name you know
V pin metrics in the yellow you don't
really have to read it if you don't want
to but there are like the parameters
there uh as the function signature and
green we have the description of the
function and we have the parameters with
the description of each parameter in
blue it's kind of a lot but it's all
there I didn't have to write this twice
it just automatically got created into
this website and it was super cool you
know I've got this bulletin Point list
of parameters looks all
right but what was lurking underneath
the surface of sphinx was the fact that
this was all in restructured text and I
had to write a lot of custom python code
uh to maintain this in the long term and
that did not feel just right for me so
although I had this dock site up it felt
maybe not ideal for me as a developer as
someone who didn't want to spend a lot
of time developing my docs so my quest
for the just right docs work uh docs
framework
continued and right when I felt all hope
was lost I would never have the perfect
porridge uh one of my colleagues Michael
Chow who works on the Cordo team and
kind of the mlops team at posit tuned me
into a project that he was working on
and Cordo do is a python package that
generates a function reference page for
your Cordo website and I am maybe like
this is a self-appointed title but I am
cord's biggest fan I think it can do no
wrong it is beautiful and I was able to
have Cordo and python docs at the same
time I was able to get beautiful API
docs we can see here uh with Cordo I
didn't make any uh weird translations
this is just kind of out of the box I
have the name of the function that we
saw before this function signature in
yellow the same description and I had a
really nice uh markdown table of
parameters so I have the name the type
the description and the default for each
of the parameters and this was really
cool it felt like a little bit better
way to ingest things rather than a
bulleted Point list uh and I was really
happy so people had these API docs and
they also were able to write uh their
long format vignettes in Python now uh
and it's just marked down but Cordo was
built to have a really pleasant
experience for writing technical
documentation and Quoc was able to let
me lean into that uh and really put
these tools together so as a developer I
kind of felt like I was winning the
lottery it was quick to get started I
pip installed Cordo do I did a little
bit of
configuration and then I ran two
commands Cordo do build and Cordo do
preview and I feel like people get a
little scared when they have like little
bit of configuration in the middle of
the slides but I promise you these 17
lines of code uh or of yl will give you
a fully functioning doc site it kind of
feels like magic and because this is
yaml it looks and feels like a bulleted
Point list which means it's super
literate and maintainable for me later
on I'm not trying to Wrangle scripts uh
I just get to put this in the Cordo doyo
file if you're a Cordo user you realize
this is actually just the same file
you're using anyway to create your site
it's just got a few extra lines at the
bottom and if we want to go line by line
of like how to make a Cordo do website
you're going to start with a yaml chunk
that's Cordo do
specific and you if you want uh you can
have this sidebar that Cordo do will
create for you and you actually don't
really have to touch this but if you
think about uh how you're ingesting
documentation you kind of have like the
function here and a sidebar of all the
other functions on the side this is when
it is being
created you also have to say the name of
the package you would like to document
um it needs to be imported into the
environment you're running this in and
then you get to create your index page
and this page is kind of like the
landing page for all your functions
you're going to give it a title like my
golden functions and a description that
they are just right it's going to be a
scrollable list of all your functions
separated by however many headers you
would
want and underneath these headers you
list what you would like to
document here we can see uh I have my
house function and then my Goldilocks
class and actually if you just wanted to
list your classes out uh that would be
just fine but if you want to have a a
less nested structure uh and see every
single uh attribute and method in the
sidebar you can list them out this way
for a little bit of a like a flatter
architecture if you just wanted to put
Goldilocks alone uh if you clicked on
Goldilocks on your sidebar it would put
all of these attributes and methods
automatically in your documentation so
you're not missing out on
information and with that little bit of
configuration I had a great site that
looked something like
this you can see on the Le hand side we
have our sidebar we have our index page
here with my title and my different uh
pieces of version deploy and there's
monitor below if you're familiar with
the V
framework and because this website is
built with Cordo you get all of the
Cordo goodies like just in there which
is amazing you get to write in
markdown uh because you're uh getting
all of these reference Pages generated
as Cordo markdown
files there's accessibility built into
quto you have high contrast highlighting
you have accessible sizing an easily
customizable alt text for any of the
images inside of your website and quto
is able to grow from one page like how I
started with vver to larger sites and
while vver is a pretty simple and
straightforward website because I don't
get a lot of joy in um like building
websites besides this one uh you can
take it from other people in the python
Community Ibis is another python package
that just moved their docs to the Cordo
do framework and they leverage a lot of
this extensibility that's built into
Cordo and Cordo do you can see that
they've added some really fun
highlighting uh they have this bolded
kind of you know explanation of the
different columns their types are in
Gray we've got you know beautiful green
and teal coloring uh to match the rest
of the Vibes of their site and mostly
they were just able to to develop inside
of Cordo do and make something that felt
just right for them but we're not really
um building docks for just us uh we want
users to enjoy these things as
well and Cordo do gives you something
that feels predictable so when I was
actually building this talk I talked to
some data scientists and they they knew
R and they were learning just enough
python to be dangerous and they had said
one of of the hardest parts of learning
python was they would like go into these
websites and they would expect to see
like you know that really structured
like format you know where to go to find
everything they're like where am I
supposed to go in these python sites I
feel
lost and Cordo do leans on some of these
lessons that are learned from package
down and it starts people off with kind
of this index page and then you have
your reference page and you can build on
from there so developers like me don't
have to worry so much about about like
how to drive SEO or like how to organize
this website so people can find things
like I can just focus on the content so
people can enjoy the
package one of the last and most magical
uh elements of Cordo do and the Cordo
kind of ecosystem is you can use wasm
elements inside of these documentation
systems kind of easily easily in a wasm
way which is already kind of magic so
the shiny for python docs are also in
Cordo do uh and if you scroll on to
almost any one of their functions and go
to the example at the bottom of the page
there is a fully functioning shiny app
running in the browser and we've got
great people in the session right after
me we're going to explain a little bit
more about how this Wizardry works but
for now I just want people to appreciate
how powerful it is that you can be on a
documentation system and be running code
learning this on the fly you know
editing this shiny app without even
having to download it is an incredible
learning experience for
users so I have been a delighted user of
Cordo do and I have to say a really
heartfelt thank you to Michael Chow from
The Cordo team at posit who's done all
this amazing work to make my life easier
Goldilocks in our lens is a Hospitality
story where Goldie walks uh she felt a
little lost she found a home and Cordo
do that felt just right thank
you thank you we have caught up so there
is time for questions all right okay so
can quarto do do parameter documentation
inheritance like the roxygen inherit
params
tag I would love to have whoever asked
this question question talk to me and
Michael Chow later because I don't know
enough about the r side to understand
that
entirely uh does quarter do support
cross
references the way you very awkwardly
can do in sphin restructured text there
are cross references um and it does so I
actually I had a Spinx website um that
you guys saw before I had a Cordo do
website and it really did feel like a
good
like Drop in uh replacement like I
thought I was going to be feeling like
oh no I'm losing stuff because uh Sphinx
it feels like it has everything like the
Sphinx ecosystem is huge like I'll just
install 17 more extensions and finally
my dock site will be perfect um but I
felt like move making this jump I didn't
lose out on any of these extensions I I
got what I needed kind of out of the box
uh with much less custom python in my
package I'll do one more can you
generate a default configuration yamamo
file automatically using some equivalent
of the use this package uh there is not
but you can copy and paste uh from the
Cordo do website which is not a super
satisfactory answer but it is an answer
nonetheless
um and I also have to plug Michael Chow
the incredible creator of Cordo do um is
always looking for people to help uh
make new package documentation so if you
open an issue on the cord. GitHub repo
allegedly he will help you build your
documentation site okay that seems like
a great place to stop so let's thank
Isabelle and all of our speakers in this
track once
[Applause]
again